back for blood the co-op zombie survival
game and spiritual successor to left 4
dead is now available for everyone i
don't think it's a terribly complicated
game and it's designed to get you and
some buddies shooting as quickly as
possible that said in my time with the
game i have discovered a few tricks and
other things of note that will improve
your experience in the fight against the
written
i really wish they just called them
zombies
[Music]
but let's start with a bit of a warning
as its name suggests back for blood is
all about that sweet sweet 4 player
co-op but does the game offer solo play
yes
but you might not want to play it solo
campaign as it's called is a separate
option in the menu that limits almost
all forms of progression that means no
achievements no stat tracking and no
supply points the in-game currency used
to unlock new cards and cosmetics the
only thing you can unlock in solo are
new acts and levels as you play through
but without earning the achievements and
supply points you would have gotten
playing online it's gotta feel bad and
no you can't play the online mode and
set everyone to bots it forces you to
match make developer turtle rock studios
has already made a statement about this
on twitter saying that it is discussing
ways to address the lack of progression
in solo mode but with no time frame for
when said changes might occur your best
bet right now is to just avoid solo mode
altogether
back for blood's card and deck manager
is the game's big feature to help it
stand out from left 4 dead letting
players essentially create custom
classes it's still a bit too early for
me to have some amazing game breaking
bills to recommend to you although i'm
sure you can find some on the internet
but i do have some advice to help you
get started now i know i just said that
solo is kind of worthless but that's not
completely true as you can use it as a
testing ground for dex solo has his own
separate deck manager with access to all
of the cards from the get-go meaning you
can spend the time building the ideal
deck or testing out certain cards in
solo and see if you like them then once
you earn those cards you can recreate
that deck online
that said deck building systems and
games can be real hit or miss for
players either it is extremely yours and
you're eager to put in the time
or you don't care and just want to play
the game so if you're the latter first
off i wouldn't stress it too much having
an amazing deck build isn't essential to
success certainly not the beginning of
the game and not on recruit difficulty
just play the game using one of the
default decks you'll earn cards slowly
but steadily from supply lines giving
you the space to see if you like the
card you just earned and not
overwhelming you with a massive list of
them as you play the game you'll figure
out what playstyle you like and then you
can start building a deck around that
if you find yourself enjoying melee
weapons give yourself some melee cards
really is that straightforward and if
you really just have no interest at all
hey you can always look up deck bills on
the internet
last tip i have around decks is that the
order of your cards actually matters so
place the cards with perks you want
right up at the top a great pick to
start with would be a fortune card like
copper scavenger which increases copper
pile spawns leading to a larger boost in
the long run
let's talk about melee no not melee
weapons but the dinky little bash attack
everyone has where you sucker punch a
zombie the thing is it's not very
effective at killing but rather pushing
a ridden away from you to give you some
breathing room but wouldn't you rather
just kill him that's why regardless of
what deck you're building i recommend
you include the card combat knife which
turns that pitiful bash into a full on
knife stab capable of killing basic
ridden with one thrust now that you'll
actually be using your knife bash more
often here's a pro tip it doesn't
interrupt your reload so next time
you're swarmed by zombies and need to
reload remember to melee and get in a
few extra kills
one of the most useful things you can
come across in a run is a locked door
these special rooms typically contain
several piles of copper good weapon
drops hell stations etc they're always
worth opening but you do need a tool kit
you can get lucky and find them in the
world but your safest option is to buy
them from the shop in the safe room
coordinate with your team and make sure
you always have at least one tool kit on
hand typically there is only one lock
door in each level but it is possible
for there to be multiple so that is
worth considering
chances are you aren't always going to
be playing back for blood with a group
of friends and will be relying on randos
through the matchmaking it's also pretty
likely they won't be using voice chat at
least not intentionally and let's be
honest you probably don't want to use it
yourself this is where the game's
excellent ping system becomes your best
friend pointing out special ridden ammo
weapons or whatever is as simple as
pressing a button cue on pc and left
bumper on consoles remember you are a
team so help your buddies out and ping
anything you're not interested in taking
yourself
you might think you have to play all the
way through an act in one go but that is
not the case after the end of every
level you can leave the game and return
to fort hope and your progress will be
saved for you to return to later maybe
you just want to take a break or spend
some supply points to unlock new cars
and cosmetics speaking of if you do end
up modifying your deck and then return
to an in-progress act those changes will
not carry over you are stuck with the
deck you started the run with and you
can't swap characters part way through
cosmetic changes like outfits and weapon
skins will apply though the good news is
that you can have multiple runs saved at
the same time so you can play a new run
queued up through matchmaking without
having to worry about overriding the run
you're playing with a particular group
of friends
hey so you know how the ps5 controller
has a built-in microphone and how it
defaults to being on and
everyone was worried they'd forget about
it joined a multiplayer game and whoops
now everyone can hear you talking to
your family or eating chips
yeah it's kind of a problem sure this
isn't specific to back for blood but
it's the first game where i've noticed
it in a major way in fact unintentional
dual sense microphones became a thing
with every single ps5 player that joined
our game every single one
remember this game has cross play so pc
and xbox players are not immune to this
problem so please for your own sake as
well as the sake of the people you are
playing with make sure that is off
and there you have it if you enjoyed
this video make sure to hit like and sub
and if you have any back for blood tips
you want to share with your fellow
cleaners post them in the comments we're
all here to help each other out and as
always thanks for watching
got a bad feeling
get up